فيما تقترب من اتمام عامها الاول بات
ميدان العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا رهن
تقدم روسي في الشرق وحرب شوارع في ضخمه
حيث يحاول الجيش الروسي بسطه الكامله على
المناطق الاوكرانيه وفي المقابل تقوم قوتك
روسيا بدعم عسكري ولوجستي من القوى
الغربيه حيث تتوقع هجوم الروسيا واسعا هذا
الشهر في اخر التطورات مشاهدينا افادت
قوته فاجنر بانها باتت تحاصر مدينه باخمت
من الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه لتصل الى
اطراف مدينه قسطنطين وتسيطر على الطريق
السريع الذي يوصل الامدادات العسكريه من
قسطنطين فيما تدور معارك داريا في
ايفانوفكا باطراف ضخمه وفي نفس المحور
الجنوبي بحسب قائد قوات باجنر دائما بينما
تتقدم القوات الروسيه من المحور الشمالي
بضواحي باخمت وتحاول السيطره على بلدات
اضافيه وتتقدم نحو سيبرسك عبر سوليدار